et
[Musique]
jadot qu à trouver un moyen pour pondre
plusieurs jeux à la fois les premiers
shadoks de la nouvelle génération
lunaire vont éclore en attendant cet
heureux événement le vous invitons à
assister aux cours de faux logis du
professeur shadow co d'une façon
générale tout neufs se compose de trois
parties l'intérieur l'extérieur et
l'antre 2 il faut savoir que l'intérieur
et l'extérieur sont en réalité une seule
et même chose quand on pond un oeuf
normal en effet vous avez sans doute
remarqué qu'il est souvent d'usagé de
l'intérieur se transforme petit à petit
en autre chose qui varie selon les cas
mais qui dépend le plus souvent de la
composition de l'extérieur l'expérience
nous prouve que si l'on à un extérieur
en poule par exemple convenablement
disposés autour d'un oeuf l'intérieur se
transforme petit à petit en extérieur ce
qui est de l'intérieur et d'un
équivalent à l'extérieur et nous
autorise à énoncer de nouvelles
définitions suivant il noté toute offre
se compose de deux parties
l'extérieur est l'antre 2
l'intérieur et l'extérieur sont qu'une
seule et même chose
l'autre de évidemment ne sert plus à
rien dans ces conditions la seule et la
vraie déflation à la came apparition est
la suivante toute offre se compose
uniquement est essentiellement dexter si
telle était la façon désinvolte dans les
shadoks définissait leurs oeufs
il faut avouer que les oeufs le leur
rendait bien
et donc peser le plus supporter ical de
retraite c'est ce qui explique pourquoi
le problème des oeufs avaient toujours
été chez déjà d'aucun problème métier
ciment problématique du premier qui
voulut d'éclore il sortit il sortit ceci
fera l'été raté le deuxième était pas
beaucoup mieux vu était pas beaucoup le
troisième est bien ma foi
quand on vous disait que le problème des
yeux était un problème excessivement
problématique
vous en avez devant vous la preuve vivre
enfin pas tellement vivante que çà et là
qu'est ce qui avait bien pu se passer
[Musique]
m